all across this country in all of these
cities
we see an escalation
of
black young men killing young black men
wherever you go indianapolis
baltimore
houston
new orleans
chicago brooklyn there is a a rise
even during the pandemic
and i want to know from your perspective
what what do you think is causing
all of this violence
[Music]
hello everybody my name is pastor corey
brooks and you got it i'm still here on
the south side of chicago on this roof
living in this tent for 100 days from
november the 20th to february 28th
bringing attention and awareness of the
violence but also to raise as much money
as we can to build a community center in
a much-needed neighborhood
the neighborhood is called o-block named
after a young man named od perry who was
shot and killed we decided to keep the
oath but call it opportunity block so
that's why i'm here trying to create
opportunity for as many people as i
possibly can and tonight i'm so grateful
that i have with me my brother all the
way from brooklyn
pastor gil monroe who is here and i want
to talk to him tonight because we do
some of the similar work he's in
brooklyn i'm in chicago i have project
hood he has the god squad and they are
doing wonderful work and i want to i
want to ask him a question because i
i woke up with this on my mind
all across this country in all of these
cities
we see an escalation
of
black young men
killing young black men
wherever you go indianapolis
baltimore
houston
new orleans
chicago brooklyn there is a a rise
even during the pandemic
and i want to know from your perspective
what what do you think is causing
all of this violence
so yeah thank you so much uh pastor cory
brooks for that um
i think
we have to look at resources right and
you could never
look at a community outside of the
resources
if you have schools that are failing
if you have
schools that are training up young men
to read at a third grade level
if you have a system that is billing
as i heard
jail cells based on third grade scores
that's a problem it's a failure it's
it's it's you're setting up young people
for failure
so i think that is also an
a thing when it comes to education as
well
with the whole idea that only a college
degree is worthwhile in america
trade schools are no longer
the you know the order of the day
and then also too we have young people
who have lost their way because they're
not seeing
within themselves that they can be
something
if you have a generation that thinks
that they're not going to live beyond 21
and that nothing around them
is only dead and no possibilities of the
future
and we are raising a generation
who themselves don't believe that they
should be alive and that's a problem
that's the problem i mean
anytime you start
having young men who think
i'm not going to live past 21
so what difference does it make that's
something that we need to deal with as a
culture
i want to ask you another question real
quick as we talk about
uh the violence that's escalating
what role do you think
uh
i heard you call it a fake culture right
what what role do you think this fake
culture plays in the escalation of this
violence a lot uh most people that
disrespect it take for instance
um you have uh pop smoke who's from you
know kanasi from brooklyn
um a young man who
uh was was was doing great in terms of
musically wise
and uh it is it is said that the people
the young people who shot and killed him
was young they were teenagers they saw
that he posted a whole load of cash on
on instagram
and i think that there was a mistake
that his address was posted
and so
that's a fake culture like you believe
that you can can can kill someone for
something that you did not work for or
something that's not yours and that
you'll get away it's a false reality
you know so we want them to set great
examples when you talk about
and we're not talking about culture
on the sense that we're saying that
every rap or every
hip-hop artist
speaks debt over young people
but we're saying that if you're going to
have a lifestyle
that is going to cause you to die
then that lifestyle is not worth dying
for
if you're doing anything that is going
to cause you to die
i don't think that again that lifestyle
could be sustainable so that's why i
call it fake culture believing
in what is not believable
and trying to achieve something that you
could never attain
the only real piece that you'll have is
making sure that you walk upright and
how can a young man cleanse his ways by
taking heat to the word of god and the
word of god could be what your parents
said just basic advice from your
principal from your teachers from loved
ones who have gone before and i think
again young people need to understand
that what you see on social media that's
not real life
that's that that's what i call uh the
fakeness of it thank god
listen
that's the reason why we do what we do
our goal is to try to change as many
lives as we possibly can
not just change them but save them as
well
and so
continue to take this journey with me
for this 100 days
continue to tune into our rooftop
revelations
thank you as always for supporting our
work and trying to help us build that
community center from all across america
you have been a tremendous blessing
thank you so very much and as i always
say until the next time
peace
you